now today we're gonna try all the lunch
items on the Starbucks menu so our first
item is chicken mangia man should I go
sandwich I think it's gonna be good
because I can't pronounce that word so
they're making it fancy wanna see the
inside yeah looks cheesy I think there's
some stuffing in it cheers Cheers good
I like the red sauce I think it's a
little dry I like that
I like the cheese I would buy this again
but I would get 2 I would get this again
this is a turkey Reuben Oh some purple
she's pretty oh it's so purple this is
better the red cabbage adds a good
moistness yeah I agree
I was really moist if I got the star
points I'm gonna get this sandwich
number three we got barbecue sriracha
sandwich I like spicy but I'll try it
oh it's this bread bread and it's very
hard this is just so insanely dry it's
like a plane my verdict is not today not
tomorrow for me it's a mozzarella roast
pepper sandwich look at this bread look
at that cheese Mystica vegetarian
oh it is I like me my vegetarian food
yet I love pesto very aromatic it's good
I really like it
I think the texture is matte wall
together yes no yes yes definitely yes
crispy grilled cheese sandwich very
cheesy well it's so very very oily it
tastes like a cheese it I feel like
there's like no cheese or maybe the
cheese all melted today drew mine might
taste only like cheese tastes more
cheesy if you want cheese bread does
Ilya creamy this is great for soup yes
today for me
this is a chicken and fig spread
sandwich
okay I like soft bread I like the
sweetness in it mm-hmm cranberries I'm
not a huge cross person so this is what
I do this is all I have left
but then there's that's the whole
sandwich right there yes for me you're
going to Hollywood for the next one we
got is turkey Havarti sandwich I like
how there's so much sauce news again
that's a good another cold sandwich
actually if you buy this
don't break it in half or use a knife
this one is actually a little too Irby
for me I like it I took out the cheese
why I'm the best part it's too much oh
maybe yes oh my god look salad this is
Starbucks Mikado fantasy this is what I
usually get when I get my Starbucks
points you're really all about this
point I love the point system usually
but I'm not a fan of feta I'm very picky
with cheese oh that's why you took out
the cheese in the sandwich okay you can
have that side it's not olives you can't
appreciate it if you can't eat the
olives and the cheese what else can you
eat chicken this side done what you just
don't like salads no I love salads well
you only this one right it's okay it's
all right oh it's a lot I would not get
this
that's our chicken and lemons hmm this
one looks so good oh I don't think is
gonna work it'll work you gotta get this
up-down motion you can actually really
mix a like that learning something every
day
Cheers oh it's too sweet it tastes like
the smell of a new cabinet what more
does new captains I don't understand
what all is this bacon grains
oh you messy let's take a bite with all
the components okay oh my God look at
you don't look at bad don't worry about
it
mm-hmm like some people like fruits in
their salad so I think if you like that
type of salad you would enjoyed this I
don't like fruits in my salad so it may
be for me after taking the bite with
everything in it I think my answer would
be a yes I'm actually very excited to
try this because I would always see
people take it I was like to go these
are adult Lunchables adult tables I'm
very very excited for not that part
simonize give you the part I don't like
what the fruit yeah I don't like fruits
what I love vegetables are you kidding
me love vegetables I hate fruits the
grapes are phenomenal real nice and
supple
how are the apples are these two
different apples it is it's who is oh
this way I already tried a bit of it
this is good better lunch though
breakfast oh well yeah this is the lunch
menu I thought it was a breakfast menu
this is like my mid lunch snack this is
a multigrain very healthy no let's me
try it has raisins no I like it I don't
like it doesn't say what kind of Jesus's
but goes well with the bread
see it is my seat this is not what
you're supposed to do this together is
really really good a cheese egg and
bread would I buy it no for lunch
I'd be starving after this but for a
snack could be a yes this is a PB&J with
fruits and veggies it's so tiny this is
a meal for ants look at this let's see
how this tastes
oh it too has its own unique taste
whoo ask chocolate know when you do this
first before dessert please please mom
just one you know such a bad child
these are chocolate-covered raisins this
is the best thing in this box
I like the string cheese I'm sure it's
great fully sure what here you go thank
you
someone's buying this I guess so but
what I know no everybody is
Oh bread cheese there's cheese and
crackers three type of cheese
okay this is [ __ ] I'm talking about I
need a glass of wine with
it has already comes with three slices
the way it's packaged makes me think
that it's something you bring on the go
and I wouldn't be able to eat this on
the go unless you're just like cutting
it with the crackers maybe that's why
it's so hard and you probably need to
like spread it look you know no you know
yes no yes that's not how you do it if
you're on the go no there's Jasmine look
what it's already sliced you're just
creating an extra place for no reason
yeah this would be great if you're not
on the go I would say like going to the
beach is this a full lunch my mom would
say no I would also say no but I would
buy this again cheese and fruit box yes
from me
maybe for me
[Music]
[Music]